foreign
Justin is in Hattiesburg Mississippi hey
Justin welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you Dave and John it is awesome to
talk to y'all I'm excited
absolutely how can we help
so my wife and I are on baby step two
and we're trying to get really gazelle
intense to pay off our debt and I wanted
to see if you and Dr John could speak to
the physical and mental challenge of
working 80 to 90 hours a week on the
physical side being like you know
fatigue lack of sleep and on the mental
side you know your mind just telling you
to call it a day when you still need to
grind out you know those last few hours
to make a really good week
why are you losing sleep you have plenty
of sleep time left
well I guess like you know a day you
work 16 hours and you have you know an
hour commute and you know eating and
stuff like that you may get you know
five to six and on a longer day you know
make it four hours of sleep
I often see folks try to continue the
life they were living before they went
gazelle intents
and they tried to squeeze it in meaning
I used to watch
um all the shows well now I have to just
watch my two and there's an hour right
there or there's an hour and a half and
I want to go to every single little
league game well during gazelle
intensity you're gonna probably have to
miss some games because you gotta work
some shifts and that's okay because
you're playing a longer game but I would
wonder how much
how much all in are you yeah that if
there's some of that and
yeah you check your
actual time audit on where your actual
hours are going
um number one
um then
sleep is necessary the second thing
though is is you're not asking yourself
to do this long term this is a short
Sprint
right it's not it's not this is not
sustainable for five years
that's not what we're asking ourselves
to do and I Got a Feeling Just in
talking to you that you have done
uh in the past maybe in sports or
something else you've done something
where you stretched yourself to a limit
and
um if you have if you're a person who's
done that you've experienced what any of
us that have done that uh physical or
mental or otherwise you never return to
the same shape after that that's the
benefit of the stretch
yes sir I have God has really blessed me
with a body that can handle a lot yeah
and so you know once you've done a half
marathon you've done a marathon you've
done a uh uh whatever the thing is that
pushed you physically and mentally or
whatever then you it changes your level
of confidence it changes the way your
swaggered the way you look at the world
after that because you accomplished the
goal and and you know you break the tape
and you're going through so that that's
the way that I have done it is number
one I look at it as a short-term play
and so it's not going to kill me because
right before you die from hard work you
pass out don't worry about it I mean
it's okay so but the uh so it's not
gonna kill me and uh it's short term and
then the second thing is is that I'm
gonna get more benefits than just the
money in this case you're you're doing
it to make a lot of money to get out of
debt okay but I'm gonna get character
benefits emotional psychological
spiritual benefits even relational
benefits because as a couple we now know
we can do things we didn't know we could
do before as an individual I know no I
can do do that because before I do and
it gives me a different level of well if
I can do that then I can do another
thing and if I can do that then I can do
another thing and that's that's what
this is versus being the typical Fat
American sitting on their couch watching
Netflix and never stretches themselves
at all and Justin there's some
incredible Neuroscience that is
obviously this doesn't um you can't you
can't game then or hack this system but
you've known people who get under a
squat bar and they feel that weight and
they get that weird smile and there's
been people who get under that bar and
it's like ah too heavy and they get off
one of those people says this pain is
gonna be worth this
watch this and the other person says I
need to opt out of this pain right now
and so there's it's the your mindset as
you're driving home you can be like I'm
so tired I hate all this is the worst
I'm so tired I just clicked another
click how long you've been married
we've been married five years how's she
doing with all this
um so that's interesting you asked that
uh one of the other kind of hard things
for me is like say that she has a day
off and I'm at work you know when it's
those last few hours when I still got
you know four hours left and I'm already
tired and she sends me a text like you
know I miss you ready to see you I'm
thinking myself I'm like man I'm ready
to see you too I want to come home but
I'm like you know I need to stay here
another few hours yeah it's like I know
you lost 50 pounds but here's some fresh
baked cookies
but also also again that's your mindset
bro because she's reaching out saying I
want you to know I'm not at work with
you but I'm in this with you
right and it's real easy for you to be
like oh yeah you know I mean it's so
yeah do your best to I mean you're all
in a short Sprint uh do do your best to
roll that out and the good news is she's
not she's not whining about she's not
going hahaha oh yeah you never you're
never home with me why aren't you ever
home with me she's not doing that to you
she just said man I miss you I wish you
were here because I'm I'm married to a
country girl it's a hillbilly and if if
they learned one thing at her house
growing up it was unbelievable hard work
she has no patience for people that
won't work hard especially if it was her
husband and so I got the opposite I'm
like get your butt out of here and get
this mess cleaned up what's wrong with
you you know and so it was she kicked me
out the door you know and so yeah
occasionally now when I don't need to
work she's like would you go to work and
get away you know it's like and so um
you know so the uh uh but she but that
so I had the benefit of a spouse that
was beyond supportive supportive is not
the correct she supported you with her
foot with her foot that's it but I mean
you know in your case you've got a sweet
one that's being sweet and saying I I
miss you but I'm proud of you so you
might even tell her that just go Hey
listen when you do that it it makes me
not angry with you but it makes me angry
with this whole situation it makes it
hard to work five more hours so if you
would do that and just add to the end of
it I'm proud of you you got this it sure
would help me when my wife is pregnant
with Josephine after
um she had we had had Hank she gave me a
list it was just not a long list but it
was a short list but she gave me a list
of questions I was not allowed to ask in
the hospital
and when she was in labor and I said why
did you do this and she said because I
know you love me and I know you're going
to ask
how are you feeling does that hurt are
you okay do you need anything and she
said when you ask those questions it
makes me want to strangle you I want to
set my eyeballs on fire just enough to
look at your face your eyeballs right so
she said the best way you can love me is
don't do this I'll let you know if I
need some and so I think for you just
like Dave just said if you let her know
hey when you reach out ah man I know
you're telling me that you're proud of
me you love me but it just makes me hate
being at work and which makes me hate
myself and makes me hate all this yeah
can you just text me and say I'm so
proud of you and I'll know that you miss
me when you're when you're running the
stadium stairs
um
you you have no memory of doing that
when you look at the scoreboard at the
end of the Super Bowl when you won oh
you make that catch yeah you have no
memory of running a stadium stairs your
brain just your brain allows you to do
the only celebration Justin your stud
man I'm proud of you and I think you're
gonna be okay uh the good news is you're
smart enough to talk about it and say
I'm tired you're smart enough to even
take a look take okay I gotta take a day
I'm done I gotta take at least a day I
can't breathe you know where your limits
are but pushing those limits is not a
permanent thing it's not a way of life
it's a moment in time and the benefits
are going to exceed the pain I can
promise you live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else